we are glad you are with us tonight as
this will be the 23rd and final game the
blue jays will play at salem fiat girabi
ray looking for win number nine tonight
here's the 1-0 pitch popped up and
playable
out in shallow center field simian going
back here comes springer to pick him up
there's a fastball hit on the ground
murrell was wide on the mark perfect
pass to robbie ray
the red sox starter is garrett richards
five and five in the area of 4.91
3-2
and got him that was filthy yeah
back-to-back sliders gets the punch out
and he does
put him away struck him out two k's for
garrett richards in the first
good count for raphael he's gonna take
ball four he's been doing that a lot
martinez hits it hard nice stop at third
across the diamond long throw in time
good play by cavendishia he saves extra
bases for roddy ray and he did the right
thing never even thought about second
knew the only play was across the
diamond two two pitch
was looking for that slider and ray
crossed him up he delivers the fastball
on the inside corner and gets his first
strikeout of the ball game task
hernandez steps in
hits that ball hard up the middle
through for a base hit so he is now five
for nine against richards three two to
grichik
runner on the move
high chop chavis nice play guns to first
to get him
went up high to snag that that could
have been a disaster a little chopper
over his head
and the 3-2
oh he gets a rocket instead he pulls it
down the line fair ball that got to the
wall in a hurry
he gets to second base in a hurry
now the heck would ball four when you
can do that boy he cleaned that out man
he was all over it
so [ __ ] to climb in old for want to fly
to center field but four career home
runs against robbie ray
there's another shot that one drilled to
the wall
and it's gone
a sizzling line drive
you can hang your wash on that one
you said it it was a sizzler he got on
top of this and scorched it
1-2
fly ball deep and santander the track
leaping to make the catch
you might have thought he was a little
closer to the wall he actually was i
think that's why you saw the smile in
his face
raphael walked in the second red sox had
two nothing in the fourth
swung on fly ball center field that
one's back there back there she's gone
rafael denver is with number 24.
he'd like to jog and he does to make it
three nothing red sox are killing the
ball here i'll tell you that ball came
off his bat high slider he stung it so
he moved to the bottom of the fourth